- Frankly, I did a bunch of
research before joining Vayner
and that was a big part of
my decision to come here was
knowing what Gary spoke of.
To see that he's walking the
walk is really cool,
not just talking the talk.
(upbeat music)
- I adore you, and I hope
you're having a wonderful day.
Right, DRock.
- Right.
- Say happy birthday, DRock.
- Happy birthday.
- You're supposed to say,
"Happy birthday, DRock."
I'm just kidding.
We love you Claude.
I wanted to just get, and
we can do this together.
It's the same thing
from my standpoint.
When we had a really great dinner
(bleep) and the (bleep) that got
brought up, and probably why I
opened my big mouth and said,
"Okay (bleep) you want to,
if this is so important,
we want to be a
more important partner."
There's not a lot of people that
are just going to be willing to
open up an office ad hoc
quickly just 'cause.
That's the advantage of
being and entrepreneur.
A lot of mention today, and I'm
sure you'll be beeping out quite
a bit, DRock, of
different offices.
I would have to take the (bleep)
scope and reverse engineer it.
I'd also need to
speak to the (bleep)
slash--
(bleep) as a whole, so I'd like to
understand what is available or
not (bleep) environment.
I believe that VaynerMedia
needs to very much consider 5,
6, 7, 8 offices in different
parts of the country that are
not LA, we're in LA,
SF, London, New York.
I believe that the IP that we
get from different perspectives
not only from people that
grew up in those areas, but by
actually being grounded in
Chattanooga, Tennessee, and
these 4 to 6 other cities that
are vying, you know it's fun,
they're vying for VaynerMedia
to go there because by us
setting up shop there, we invite
more entrepreneurial spirit,
other companies, I bring
company, there's a lot going on
in Chattanooga that is benefitted.
I think they're important to
VaynerMedia because the clients
we have and the ambitions I have
as a business man long term,
we need to be grounded in
the IP of those markets.
We need to understand what Sal's
DNA is in San Antonio, Texas.
We need to understand Karen's
ambitions in Topeka, Kansas.
We need to understand how
Katherine with 3 kids in
Walla Walla, Washington thinks
about the world, not just the
people that role in LA,
so I'm very conscious of that.
It's on strategy.
I plan on putting up 10 flags in
cities like that across America.
We'll go international.
We'll look at the Singapore's
and the Sydney's and the
Helsinki's and the Montreal's
and the Mexico Cities' and the
Sao Paulo's as well.
Then maybe in a 15, 20 year
period, we'll start looking at
the suburbs of the these
major countries as I continue to
navigate the growth
in my business career.
- Talk to you later.
Dude, what is up my man?
- You live in LA.
- I'm so LA'd out.
- Are you super LA'd?
- I love it. I love it.
- It's the best right?
- I'm like yeah, but--
- Dude, I got to be
honest with you,
like I'm starting to
get weird about it.
I'm 100% decided that I'm
going to buy a place out here.
- Are you? You know
what it's not--
- It's where I'm
going to spend my--
- It's not the LA
you knew 10 years ago.
It's a different thing.
- 100%.
Look at that guy.
He went all black today.
All black?
- [Man] Always.
- Oh yeah.
- I love it.
- What's up brother?
- You good?
- Great, I'm great.
- What's going on?
- All good stuff.
Let's do it.
So what's happening?
- What are you in town for?
- Have you guys bought
every one of these buildings?
- That's crazy.
- Is that what happened?
- Have you ever like--
- Yeah, I've been here a bunch.
- Done the whole
thing, so it's like
- I mean, every time I come,
there's like six new buildings.
- It's all there's like six
new ones since then.
A lot of it is like hiding out.
- It's so ad hoc.
- It's so on the DL--
- [Woman] Hi.
- How are you?
- [Woman] Oh my god,
there he is.
- Hello.
- [Woman] The legend.
- That's what, I like that.
That's how I like to--
that's how I like--
- Susanne Grant.
- Susanne, how are you?
- I'm on the agency team.
- How are you doing?
- Nice to see you.
- We met in that
little theater, right?
Back then?
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I remember.
- I know, the legend.
My husband and I watch
it, like all the time.
We cannot get away from it.
- Thank you.
- Are you doing a
little interview?
- No we're just
jamming a little bit.
- He's here for a job.
- DRock's doing the job.
- Really, I heard things
aren't going well for you.
I'm so sorry.
- No, all falling apart.
- Right, right.
- I'm hoping I can help.
If I start from the bottom
here, I think I can help.
- No, no, no, listen.
I just hope things improve.
It's been hard for you.
I mean, success is not for him.
- No, it's poison.
How are you doing?
- I'm fantastic.
- You good?
- We're working,,,
(light music)
- Just to get the hint.
- Oh, I see.
DRock's going to be
happy because better shots.
Holy shit, DRock, look at that.
DRock is...
you did it, for DRock.
You did it.
Went to the top of Venice.
I'm here for this meeting.
I surrounded
everything else around today.
This meeting, so I feel so
safe because I have a budding
relationship with him, but I
feel so safe in your hands.
Tell me what to do and
we will get it done.
I don't want to
miss this moment.
This would be, in the way of
like in my career, like,
passing on--
this would be up there with
passing on Uber,
in the angel round, twice.
Even though that like,
I don't joke in the fact
that that probably lost me
250 million dollars.
I'm not so sold that if I miss
this, it doesn't cost me
250 million dollars.
Here's why.
I just think that if I do this,
it will change my life.
You know, one of the great
things about doing this DailyVee
is do you know how bad I
wish that this camera and this
amazing man was with me when I
first walked into Twitter when
there was 8 employees there.
Do you know how
amazing that would be?
Just the history, by the
way, just the B-roll for our
conversations around Twitter, or
when I gave that keynote to most
of Facebook, when they were a
much different, smaller company.
Or that first meeting I had with
David Karp, talking about my
excitement for where Tumblr
was going, or when I flew out to
meet with Google and Yahoo
about YouTube and Yahoo video.
Or that day in Paris when I
first met the Travis,
the future CEO of Uber.
Catching these B-rolls of these
early meetings of Snapchat,
2, 4, 6, 8 years before they will
be one of the establishments,
even though in my mind
they're establishment again.
For all those small cities or
all the 50 year olds that aren't
paying attention, they don't
know it yet the way I know it.
The way I see it, and so
I'm passionate about that.
I'm passionate about capturing
these moments, having those
meetings and those early days of
establishing those relationships
with the leading platforms in
the world and really showing
that framework for all you
entrepreneurs, that one of the
great things is, when there
isn't anything tangible or
anything too crazy, still
building those relationships,
whether they're with Sean from
Snapchat or a Roman from Patow,
they are part of the day in
and day out that maters so much.
Television is dead, this is what
matters, and are like in the
religion of this same thesis.
- Yeah.
- We'll be in touch.
- Yeah, we'll talk.
- All right.
(light music)
- You know what?
Capture me this way and get
that cool thing behind me.
- Culture is if you look outside
everybody is laughing and
smiling right now, but it is six
o'clock, so people work hard
but they have fun working hard.
- [Gary] A good culture is not
something I want to have
'cause it's fun for me to
talk about publicly.
Or it makes me feel good.
A good culture is
A) the right thing to do and
does make me feel good.
I guess I'm
contradicting myself.
It's funny I made that little
joke like actually
that's my truth.
I do like being a good guy or
it's the right thing to do.
Psst, I have a dirty
little secret for you.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
- The idea of taking the high
road and always being the bigger
person is something that has
always been a huge part of
VaynerMedia as we've scaled
and grown and now
have all these different offices.
I know how important it
is to Gary, but it's been
important to us the
group that were like
the original set
to maintain that
culture and what makes
it special to work here.
I think for some people here it
was probably not a new message,
but still an important one
to hear it and to hear it from
Gary, from the top and the fact
that it means so much to him and
that it's not just lip service.
- The culture at
Vayner is so strong.
It was the first thing I heard
about when I interviewed here
and has been pretty consistently
pushed as really important to
the company since
I've been here.
I know Gary also believes
that going above and
beyond to should be the standard.
To hear that we're doing great
but we should be doing better,
I wasn't too worried about how
we were going to handle it.
I think we're going to really
see things improve from here.
- It has a funny,
call it fuckin' karma.
Call it whatever the shit,
the fuck you want.
Doing the right thing
is the right thing.
It always, always, always
ends up in the net score
being the right move.
Even if that net score isn't a
micro thing that happens in a
three year window on business,
you did something nice.
They eventually
became your client.
They gave you money.
They're your homie.
They give you an opportunity
that nobody else can.
Not that.
I mean, if none of that works
out when you're laying there
in sick and you can feel good
about how you lived your life,
the ultimate net score, you've won.
A great culture enables speed.
- When you genuinely like each
other and when you genuinely
understand that all of you
have the right intent in mind,
that you're not doing this because
you want to get the ribbon or
the recognition or the promotion
or whatever else, or you're just
a good person, you're not
mean or cliquey or whatever it
fucking is, when there's a
good culture, speed happens.
When you're not spending extra
time figuring out why Matt is
trying to ruin you.
Right?
Then you're in a
really good place.
So yes, do I think that in every
situation you should try to be
the bigger woman or man?
Do the right thing?
Be the nicer person?
Be the better person?
Yes, I believe in that.
Yes, I try to achieve that.
And I try.
You don't always
do it, but I try.
That intent is real.
- [Woman] I thought
it went really well.
I think it's really important
for us to always keep in mind
that culture is what makes this
agency as awesome as it is and
it's sort of always the
backbone of what keeps us going.
So I think it's a good constant
reminder for people on the west
coast and people in New York
just to hear it,
time and time again.
- The culture that I have
sensed already
here is truly exceptional.
It's a place where
people want to be.
At least that's
been my experience.
People are excited to be here,
they're enjoying the work and
I don't want to be anywhere where
that's not the case and this is
truly the first place where I've
felt that from the majority of
the people in the office.
So it's great.
- I mean, I have, like, the
Vayner culture like fully
ingrained in me, from being
there in New York and I was
really, really happy when he did
this thing and I found out about
it because I was--
like the one thing that I talked
to him about was, like, getting
him and Claude and, you know,
like James and Scott here more
often for like one-on-one,
in-person meetings because it's
just so much different,
having that leadership available
to you in New York.
And like we just don't
see those people,
like on a day-to-day basis here.
So when he said that he was like
"I'm gonna be here more often
and I'm thinking about
buying a house," and whatever,
like that is going to be awesome,
just having him here and it's going
to make this place so much
better than it already is.
- It's interesting because you
mentioned about the culture,
you know, as far as I'm concerned,
coming from start-ups and very
large companies, other agencies,
the culture here
is pretty exceptional.
- Yep.
- So what is it that's going
to change and what is it that
you're not seeing
that you want to see?
- Yeah.
So it is exceptional and I
want you guys to know that.
I just don't want one person
saying something mean about
anybody ever, ever, ever.
How about that?
- [Kate] My question to him was:
Well, if you want it to be better,
what do you feel is missing?
'Cause I wanted to know, kind
of just maybe dig in a little
deeper and understand further.
How do you take something
that's good and make it great?
So that was kind of where
my question was coming from.
But the fact that he is someone
who is not just okay with good,
who wants to take it to the next
level, is something I really
respect and I want to be working
for someone like that,
someone who has a vision and
someone who sees that there's
always an opportunity to
continually improve.
And iterate.
I think it's about evolving, too.
Knowing that as a company
grows, things have to evolve.
And just because a company gets
bigger doesn't mean that that
culture has to suffer.
So I love that he has that
vision and that's, again,
certainly someone that
I want to be working for,
who believes that.
- I know that the
culture here is phenomenal.
I'm pumped that you must be
sitting at me like woof because
I know and you guys all know.
We know, but just
imagine where the fuck I'm at.
Right? Like,
and listen, I'm not,
listen, on the flip side of what
I just said, I don't think it's
humanly natural for
what I just asked for.
Right?
I get it, but I do think I
want you guys to understand,
if that's the ambition, that you
need to save that for when it's
really needed.
Does that make sense?
It just can't be
easy to talk shit.
It's funny.
I've been writing a lot of
articles about entrepreneurship.
Do you know how tough it is when
you have nobody else to blame?
Know how much fun it is to blame
the person that's above you?
It's pretty cool.
You know how fun it
is to blame Matt?
It's fun.
You know how fun it is
for Matt to blame me?
It's fun.
For me, it's not fun.
There is nobody else.
I promise you, every single
thing that is broken here,
is my fault. Sucks.
Super lonely when you have
to make this core decision.
Look, it's my responsibility,
like, like, it's my job.
Just like I talked about,
as you just saw in the clip,
I'm sure DRock editing it nicely,
just like I talked about,
it is lonely at the top.
It's only my responsibility.
Every issue at the company is my
fault, and so you allocate the
hour and a half to give the talk
to the whole company and
you miss four phone
calls that were going on
and DRock kept looking
at me during that time.
Because it's only
my responsibility.
It's only my singular
responsibility with the Claudes
and the James and the Segels,
they're there, but at the end of
the day the buck stops with me
and I have to, with every ounce
of my soul, try to deploy my
North Star to my employees.
Know it is my challenge, and
every leaders' challenge,
all of your challenges,
to know that moment when
you've got to give that talk.
I knew it was
time for that talk.
I know there's going
to be benefit from it.
I've gotten the email.
Here's the post-game from six
hours ago, and I've gotten like
five emails already.
Good ones.
Real ones.
It's meaningful.
You've got to put in the work,
and so it's a leaders number one
job to deploy her
or his religion on
everybody underneath them.
From their right-hand man or
woman, all the way down to the
intern that started yesterday.
You've got to do that in a
million different ways and for
me, I try to put myself
in a position to win.
Not all of you are going to be
able to, or have the charisma,
or the natural communication
talent, to do an all-hands-on
meeting, but many of you
can write a manifesto.
This incredible, five-page
article, pdf, blog post,
that moves your company.
Some of you can voice it.
Some of you can do an offsite
at a cabin that you own
and that's it.
Some of you can pick the four
people that can get it from you
and then they're the
ones that instill it.
You've got to figure out your
version to communicate that
installation of your religion to
your organization, but you can't
just put your head in the sand
and not do it, because you don't
do it the way you saw
me do it or the way
you heard somebody else do it.
Figure it out.
Write a manual.
Do a seminar.
Anoint four communicators within
that translate you the best.
I don't care, but do it.
- You know it's always
great just having
Gary in the building.
I have had the luxury of knowing
him for 10 years plus, and I
know how he ticks, but not
everybody that's in this office
especially gets that
kind of access to him.
Just having him here, I think,
really makes a huge difference,
and the fact that he's going to
be here so much more often over
the coming weeks and months will
mean a lot to the development
and growth of this office.
- If you think about everything
that's going on it's like
you have to be the bigger
person where you just look dumb.
- [Gary] A great culture
enables speed.
When you generally like each
other and when you generally
understand that all of you have
the right intent in mind,
that you're not doing this because
you want to get the rhythm or
the recognition or the
promotion or whatever else.
You're just a good person,
you're not mean or cliquey or
whatever it fucking is.
When there's a good
culture, speed happens.
When you're not spending extra
time figuring out why Matt is
training you and you, right?
Then you're in a
really good place.
I want, I've done a much more
aggressive job in
New York on this issue.
I want to make sure everybody
understands in this office how
much it matters to me and how
much it is the single reason
most people get fired
at VaynerMedia.
How much I would like to elevate
what we have going on here.
We have a great thing going
on here but it's not where
I want to be.
I want to make sure everybody
understands that being the
bigger man and being the bigger
woman in every situation,
all of them, is the prerequisite,
it's not the ambition.
It's not what I hope we get
to, it's the cost of entry and
points are being tallied on the
individuals in this room that
are not playing that
game on an everyday basis.
It is the thing I care about.
You can get away with it for
four months, seven months, even
a year but you just get
away with it long term.
I highly recommend that you use
Madalina, that you use Claude,
that you use me, that you use
Matt, that you use your homies.
Whatever you need to use to make
sure whatever is bothering you
that doesn't allow you to be in
that mental place, to be that
teammate, to always,
look, the reason it's easy to be
the bigger man and woman in any
situation is you're happy
with yourself first,
you're in a good place.
It gives you the audacity and
the mental strength and the
stomach to be able to
be the bigger person.
Guys, I'm always right
or at least I think so.
When I have to be the bigger
man in a lot of situations,
it's quite hard for me and I also
have the track record and the
experience and the results
to like back my shit up.
I still have to eat shit on an
everyday basis for me
to do what I'm
asking you to do.
I promise you if I do it every
day with clients and AJ and
James and Claude and Scott and
Matt, if I do it, then I promise
you I expect you to do it.
No matter who you are or what
you do or what your fucking
title says you are.
To make that happen, I need to
make sure there's not a clique or
an individual or four random
individuals that are going to
stop it from happening the
way that I want it to happen.
I'm available for you.
If you're concerned about what
I'm saying and you know it's
predicated by you being
upset about your pay,
your opportunity,
the other person in your team,
700 other things that could
come up that make you
not as in the best place
that you can be.
Which then creates a scenario
where you are not, I'd much
rather you be on the offense
with me, I fix it and/or we talk
about it than for you to just go
down the inevitable blah path
of not being happy, not being
able to be that person that the
company wants and
then just being fired.
That's not good for you.
I'm very thankful that you're
at this company and that you
believe in me, it, the logo,
the team so I want to be
there for you.
I'm super available.
Gary@VaynerMedia, wide open
super pumped so and again I'm
going to be back here next week.
Like I'm going to be here a lot
and so I have enormous ambition
for what we're doing out here.
We have a lot going on and a lot
of very good stuff going on and
I need to elevate
the level of everything here
starting with culture, real culture.
Not you're doing it on the
surface but you don't mean it.
- Got it?
- [Gary] I feel really good about the
talk I just gave to the LA crew.
Obviously, new challenges,
satellite offices
Wine Library,
there's only one location.
I myself as an
entrepreneur am developing.
I don't talk a lot about my
shortcomings very often because
I really don't give them
a whole lot of thought.
I definitely recognize my need
to be present physically in some
of the offices,
which I'm exciting.
LA is becoming a very
important, very important,
this would be a good
shot DRock.
LA is becoming a very important
hub for us, and I think there is
some stuff going on in the
office that could go from
a 9.2 to a 10.1.
Even though the tone was
culture, culture,
LA is doing its thing.
I just want it to be better.
I always make that joke of the
people that don't do innovation
that are like,
"Business is up 60%."
What about 120, what about 400?
That's what that was.
It's not that I'm
worried about culture.
It's that I want
it to be better.
Right, guys?
- Hi.
Right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Right?
- Hello.
- Yes. Was that good?
Did you guys enjoy the talk?
- [Woman] Yeah, it was awesome.
- Good. Awesome.
- Thank you.
- Have a great day.
- [Woman] It was nice to have you here.
- Thank you.
I'll see you guys in a week.
- [Women] Bye.
(light piano music)